j'ai posé la question mais est-ce que ma
fille va mourir je croyais qu'il était
en train de mourir et on m'a dit on ne
sait pas on peut pas vous répondre et là
pour nous c'était le monde qui
s'écroulait quoi bonjour brut je suis la
maman de Julia qui a 4 ans et demi
aujourd'hui qui a contracté la bactérie
chez Richard au lit en avril 2019 elle
avait 18 mois
[Musique]
il y a 3 ans Giulia est tombé malade en
mangeant un morceau de fromage au lait
cru les médecins lui ont diagnostiqué le
syndrome hémolytique et urémique le SHU
une infection causée par la bactérie
ecoli depuis elle est handicapée à plus
de 80% et sa vie et celle de sa famille
ont basculé elle a commencé à avoir des
symptômes de diarrhée donc nous sommes
allés chez le médecin qui nous a dit bah
c'est une gastro et de là julia a
commencé à beaucoup loucher et je me
suis dit ce n'est pas normal qu'elle
louche autant donc j'ai dit bon on va
quand même aller à l'hôpital ils nous
ont expliqué qu'elle avait le syndrome
hémolytique et urémique qui est dû à la
bactérie chéri chat Colli j'ai entendu
des parents qui étaient là aussi pour
leurs filles qui avaient un CHU qui
avait goûté aussi un fromage du même
magasin et de la même fromagerie et
c'est là dans ma tête ça fait titre je
me suis dit mais oui c'est vrai qu'elle
a goûté ce fromage aussi et ensuite on a
eu les résultats d'analyse qui montrait
que c'était la bactérie au 26 et c'est
celle qu'on trouve dans le lait de vache
donc c'était logique que ça pouvait être
que ça ce syndrome attaque les reins euh
de base mais quand il y a un retard de
diagnostic que les choses sont pas
faites attendre la bactérie peut
s'attaquer à tous les organes possibles
donc Giulia avait ce retard de
diagnostic la bactérie a eu le temps de
monter jusqu'au cerveau chaque année
selon santé publique France entre 100 et
160 enfants contractent le syndrome
hémolytique et urémique dans 10% des cas
la maladie peut évoluer vers une forme
sévère on s'est rendu compte que elle
était plus elle était différente en fait
elle faisait plus rien elle bougeait
plus elle parlait plus
tout doucement elle a perdu la vue donc
leur fait elle ne voyait plus non plus
elle ne tenait plus assises plus rien
quoi et c'est là qu'on qu'ils ont
commencé à nous dire dans votre fille
elle a des grosses séquelles
neurologiques et on sait pas
comment ça va évoluer en fait elle se
sert pas encore de ses bras comme elle
voudrait parce qu'elle a des gestes
involontaires elle a jamais reparlé
depuis que elle a été
transférée
à l'hôpital de Lyon on l'a plus jamais
entendu dire un mot son quotidien Giulia
et ben c'est la rééducation donc kiné
ergo psychomotricienne orthophoniste et
le disent toujours Julia c'est une
battante elle lâche rien
le cas de Giulia est très rare moi j'ai
eu la chance on va dire de rencontrer
des parents d'une petite qui a une
atteinte neuro aussi qui m'ont beaucoup
aidé qu'il reste à eux j'ai gardé espoir
aussi si j'aurais pas les mots tellement
si je suis en colère contre les
usines dont cette usine cette fromagerie
qui n'a pas vérifié qui n'a sûrement pas
eu le contrôle quand ce magasin qui ont
vendu ce fromage alors qu'ils avaient eu
un rappel mais qui ne l'ont pas enlevé
des rayons donc normalement je n'aurais
même pas pu acheter ce fromage s'ils
avaient fait leur boulot mais mon
énervement la plus forte c'est qu'on ne
se médecin de l'hôpital et tu n'as pas
pris les choses au sérieux il y a eu
cette grosse épidémie avec les pizzas et
pour moi je trouve ça horrible qu'on en
soit encore à là donc je me dis que plus
on parle de l'histoire de Giulia et plus
les parents pourront être un peu plus
alerté en 2019 la famille de Giulia a
lancé une action en justice contre la
fromagerie le magasin et l'hôpital trois
ans après la procédure est toujours en
cours ce que j'espère en tout premier
c'est que les coupables soient avérées
et que il paie pour ça et aussi bah que
financièrement Giulia est besoins qu'il
y ait pas de barrière financière que je
puisse l'emmener ensemble de rééducation
intensif à l'étranger que tout ce qui
est appareillage et ben je puisse
qu'elle puisse avoir tout ce qui a
besoin en fait on a de l'espoir pour que
quel reparle qu'elle s'exprime pour moi
c'est le plus important mais c'est le
tienassiste quelle marche on espère
qu'elle récupère le plus de choses
possible mais ça c'est sûr que la petite
fuite elle était avant on la retrouvera
plus quoi